ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนเออ
คลิปนี้เป็นคลิปที่ 2 เนาะ
สุดานี้
วันนี้เราคุยกันวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ PHP นี้
วันที่ผู้เรียนจะเขียนไหมคะเขียนค่ะ
เดี๋ยวอย่าเขียนใช่มั้ยริมเขียนผู้เลี้ยง
คู๋ได้ยินเสียงเสียงไก่ขัน
ใช่ค่ะไก่ขันเย้
มันกูลืมว่าไก่ก่อนนะไก่
ไก่
เหมือนไหม
ไก่มานะ
/ กาตัวไก่หาโทรหาไก่อาไก่เห้ยอีกไก่
ตาไก่แต่ไก่นะคะอ่ะ
ท้ายเสียงไก่นะคะ
ไก่แล้วบอกไก่ขัน
ไก่จะขัน
จริงๆเราไม่ต้อง Copy เสียงมีเสียงแล้ว
ได้ยินได้ดินน่ะอ๋อที่บ้านของเรียน
ก็มีไก่
ครูเอ๋ชอบฟังเสียงไก่
[เพลง]
ชอบฟัง
มาบ้านหรือเหลี่ยม
ไปได้ก็จะไปบ้านครูเรียมพระเอกคุยชอบนอน
แล้วก็ฟังไกลๆไกลอ้าว
ๆไม่ทำงานแล้ว
ไปช่วยทำงาน
ใกล้ขันขัน
ไปหรือถ้าฉันไก่บอกเสร็จแล้ว
ขันเสร็จแล้วนะคะ
คุณเรียมวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันเสาร์
ค่ะวันเสาร์นี้
เมื่อ
วันเสาร์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันเสาร์ที่
18 มีคะ
18  8 ใช่ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือนธันวาคม
[เพลง]
ใจว่าแล้วเย้
เดือนธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมคศอะไรคะ
[เพลง]
2021 โอเค
2021 โอเคนะคะวันนี้วันเสาร์ตอนนี้เวลา
[เพลง]
เวลา
03:00 น 03:00 น
03:00 น
13 นาที 4
53 นาทีค่ะบ่ายสามโมงห้าสิบสามนาทีครู
เอ๋
คู๋กับครูเรียมก็จะพูดจะพูดเสร็จ
16:00 น
4:20 นนใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะเราจะพูดพูดพูดกัน
ถาม 10 นาทีนะคะ 31
ทำงานมากๆ
นักเรียนครูเอ๋นะชอบฟังเสียงไก่ขัน
ปากครูเอ๋ไม่ชอบฟังเสียงหนึ่งเสียงค่ะครู
เรียมอุ้ยครูเรียมเสียงอะไรคะที่ครูเมย์
ไม่ชอบฟังเสียงหมาหมา
เห่าหรอคะห้องหมาเห่างูอ่าโอเค
แต่ถ้าหมาวัดหมาได้ไหมคะคุณเรียมวาดรูป
หมาเต้นไหมโอ้มาหา
กูอีกว่าให้ไหมคะ
ผู้เรียนก็ได้
หมา
มุ่ยโอเคโอเค
วาดสวย
ผู้เอกว่าไม่เหมือนหมา
เคนี่หมาจะมีตาด้วยตาๆๆ
ขอ
ขอบคุณค่ะไก่
หมา
ถ้าหมาเห่าห้องๆๆๆ
ครูเอ๋โอเค
ไก่ขัน
กูเองดูดีใจเปล่งเสียงหมาหมาขอ
คู่เลียมเคยได้ยินหมาหอนไหมคะ
เคยหักเตรียมเคยได้ยินหมาหมาหอนหมาหัว
เสียงยังไงนะเสียงยังไงอ่ะถ้า
ซื้อตอนนี้หนาวหนาวใช่มั้ยหนาวแล้วหมา
คู๋นะหนาวหนาวแล้วก็ได้ยิน
น้องหมาหอนวูคนลุก
แล้วมานะ 1 ตัวหอนอ่าเดี๋ยวกูเองเป็นหมา
ตัวที่ 1 หอมกูเลียมที่ 2 นะเดี๋ยวกูเอก
กลับมาที่ 3 โอเคนะได้ๆ 2  1 ห้อง
มีหมา
เวลาหมายหมาหอน
พระที่ไหน
กวนอิมก็ได้
ไงคะมีจะไม่กวนอิมมีหนังสือพระ
หนังสือพระ
พระที่คอตต์พี่
พู่เก๋ๆกลัว
กลัวกลัวเหรอค่ะ
ผี
อ๋อ
เห
คนหิวหรือไงคนไทยพูดหมา
เห็น
อ้าย
ฮิผีจะผิด
อ๋อ
Cheap มากๆเป็นผู้หญิงผมยาว
เดี๋ยวนะอันนี้สว่างไปผีต้องหน้ามืดๆพี่
เอ๋เคยเห็นผีไหมคะ
เขียนอยู่ตอนนี้
เดียวเลี้ยงเห็นผีอยู่ใช่ไหมใช่ผีไม่มี
แว่นตาค่ะเอาแว่นเต่ามี
วิถีจะ
วิ่ง
กลัวตัวเองกลัวกลัวตัว s&p
50% โอเคที่นี่ตา
ตัวนี้เขาเรียกว่าตาถลนตาทะลักออกมา
เดี๋ยวกูอีกว่าลูกพี่
นี่โง่
นะคะลูกเตรียมยาหนูกลัวมั้ยเนี่ยสีเป็น
ยังไง
เค้กผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงซินะ
ผมยาวอาทินี่
ตาตุ๋ยโอเคอ่า
ร้านเสื้อสวยไหมคะผู้เรียนม
สีสวยใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะสวย
แต่พระเอาผมออก
ผมออกแล้วเห็นอะไรคะเอาผมตรงนี้ออก
ก็จะเห็นแบบนี้ค่ะครูเรียน
มาอันเนื้อ
เอา
เอาฮือ
ฮาจิเมะเองเอ้ย
ผี
ตาตาบขี่เป็นอะไรตาผีน่ะหลุดออกมาหลุดออก
มาใช่เขนิตาจะออกมา
คะแล้วก็คนไทยบอกผีหน้าตาหลุดออกมาได้
แล้วก็มีลิ้น
ลิ้น
ยาว
โง่
ลิ้นยาวๆแขนค่ะคุณเรียมธรรมดาแขนคนทวีป
กับผีในแขนจะอย่า
โอ้กล้องดีมากเหมือนผี
คุณ
โอโอ้โอ้ยโอ้ยไม่ใช่ halloween นะ
เดี๋ยวยาวใช่ไหมโอ้โอ้
รู้
[เพลง]
แขนยาวขอโทษนะคะขอโทษค่ะอ๋อ
ค่ะนกเขตเป็นยังไงคะพี่ล่ะข้างบ้านค่ะ
อันนี้ - พรุ่งนี้ก่อนนะคะคุยกันนี่หว่า
อันนี้ผีผู้หญิงใช่ไหมคะบางทีผีก็
ตัวสูงๆ
สูง
สู
สูงมากๆ
ขาใหญ่ๆๆ
เท้าขาวแท้ขาวเท้าใหญ่ๆ
โง่
เบอร์ใหญ่ๆ
1  2  3  4  5  5
ปากเล็กๆปาก
เล็ก
ปาก
แล้วพี่ก็ร้องอะก็
เรียงไม่ได้ยินเลยค่ะอ่ะ
เธอ
ได้ยินไหม
หนึ่งได้ยินนี่อ่ะเขาเล็กๆ
คิวคิว
ว่าแต่เขาพูดแล้วได้ยินนี่เดียวได้
โอ๊ย
เขา
เจ็บหูโอเคได้หญิงหนู
สูงขนาดไหนคะ
สูง 5 เมตร10เมตร
กู 5 ถึง 10 เมตร
โห
เวลากูเอ๋ก็นี้พ่อใช่ไหมถ้า
แม่
อ้าแล้วก็ครูเอ๋
พี่ชายโป้พีสาว
น้องชาย
พ่อเนี่ยจะบอก
ถ้าบอก
เองเห
รอ
ค่ะตีตี
ตี
คุณแม่
ตีคุณพ่อ
เวลาตาย 555 จ๊ะเอ๋ปลาย
ตายก็จะเป็นผี
[เพลง]
ผีอันนี้
เป็นไทยเรียกว่าขอเกรดผีผีเปรียด
แฮปปี้ e-pal ก็ a  a แม่มือผู้ใหญ่
มือเนี่ยจะใหญ่
อาจใหญ่
ใหญ่เช้าขาวเท้าจะใหญ่
ปากจะรีบ
[เพลง]
กินกับพูดไม่ดีด้วยพูดพูดไม่ดี
พูดไม่ดีกับคุณพ่อคุณแม่พูดไม่ดีกับพระ
โง่หาพระมีพระ
พระที่สวดมนต์พระ
ทุกข์
มันไม่มาครับพูดไม่ดีกับพราวไม่ดีพูดไม่
ดีน้อป้าก็จะเล็กๆอ่ะ
ถ้ากินไม่ได้หิวแล้วก็พออ๋อตัว
งูตัวผอมๆเพราะว่ากินไม่ได้ให้
เวลาได้ยินหมา
ผีผีอะไรหึ
ครูเอกกลัวผีผี
ผี
รู้
พูดไม่ดีตายจะเป็นผี
คุณพ่อคุณแม่บอก
ไม่ต้องสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะต้องพูดดีๆ
ไส้พูดดีๆพูดไม่ดีจะเป็นผี
จริงไม่จริงไม่รู้ก็ไม่รู้กลัวๆนะคะ
ครูคู่เรียมกลัวไหมคะผีเปน
กลัวค่ะแต่เรียมไม่เคยเห็นไม่เคยเห็นนะฮะ
ครูเอ๋เคยเห็นพิเศษไหมคะเอกเคยเห็น 1
ครั้งหา
นิลครั้ง
ลูกเอ๋เห็นที่ไหนคะเดี๋ยวกูเห็นลบนะกู
เห็นรถก่อน
ครูเอ๋เห็นผี
วุฒิตอนนั้นครูเรียม
เดือน
พฤศจิกายนค่ะ
ตอนครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋เอ๋เอ๋
อายุ
ประมาณน่าจะว่าเจ้าเปย์
อ้าวขวบพูด 9 ขวบพูด 9 ปีโอเคนะคะ 9 ขวบ
ตอนกูอายุ 9 ขวบ
อันนี้บ้านจากบ้าน
แล้วก็มีถนน
ถนน
ไปวัดนี้วัด
โง่เดือนพฤศจิกายนตอนที่พระจันทร์
พระจันทร์นะคะ
เต็มดวงพระจันทร์เต็มดวง
ใช่พระจันทร์เนี่ย
เต็มดวงกลางคืน
ตอนกินพี่นักเรียนจะมีจะมีสระน้ำ
อ๋อ
สนามแล้วก็มี
กระทง
หนูโง่มีกระทงมีเทียน
เทียนมีธูป
ไม่ใหม่
ครูเอ๋คะไปลอยกระทงที่วัดท่าใช่
ครูเอ๋ไป
นิดทำไมไม่ได้
โอเค
เก๋ไปลอยกระทงก็จะมีมีมีมีอะถ้าไม่ไป
แม่ไม่ไปอ้าวมีอี
เดี๋ยวพี่สาว
พี่ชาย
ครูเอ๋
น้องชาย
4 คนขอ 4 คนไปลอยกระทงที่วัดได้และแปล
ว่ามีเพื่อนบ้านที่นี่มีเพื่อนบ้าน
มีเพื่อนบ้าน
ทุกคนมีคนที่นี่คนคนก็ไปพืชไป
ไปเดินไปหรอคะเดินๆเดินไป
ไกลเท่าไหร่ไหมคะ
ไกลเท่าไหร่คะ 3 กิโลเมตร
3 กิโลเมตรให้เดินตอนกี่โมงคะเดินเดิน
เดินตอน
18:00 น
โอ้โหเฮ็ดหยังเย็นๆ
[เพลง]
18:00 นนี่เรียงคิดว่ามืดแล้วพระอาทิตย์
ตกได้มืดๆเดี๋ยวกูเองให้เป็นสีเทาหน้ามืด
น่ะ
เกี่ยวไหม
สีดำมืดแล้วมอง
เห็นนิดหน่อยมึงอืดๆแต่ว่า 6 โมงเนี่ย
18:00 นเป็นเป็นอันนี้อ่าน่ะมืดนิดหน่อย
งูมืดนิดหน่อยแต่ว่าครูเอ๋เอ๋นะครับพี่
พี่พี่พี่
น้องๆเดินเดินเดินไปที่วัด 3 กิโลเมตร
เนี่ยก็ 1 ชั่วโมงเนอะ
ประมาณ
[เพลง]
1 ชั่วโมง
เป็ดมาเด้อก็เดินๆ
ๆเดินเดินมาที่บ้านนี้วันนี้ก็ออกมาก็
เดินไปบ้านนี้คนนี้ก็ออกมาแล้วก็เดินก็มี
คนมากขึ้นมากขึ้นมากขึ้นก็เดินไป
เดินไปที่วัดมากง้อ
ครูเอ๋เดินไปถึงที่วัดกี่โมงค่ะ
ประมาณ 19:00 น 19:00 นเงียบประมาณ 19:00
น
ที่วัดโอเคเลยครูเรียม
ที่วัดนะมีโอ้มีรำไทย
รำไทย
มีร้องเพลงรัก
มีกระทงมี
มีไฟโหมมีไฟ
โอเคอ๋อโอเคเลยๆแต่ว่าที่ถนนเนี่ยไม่โอเค
ที่ถนนมีต้นไม้
ขนนไม่มีไฟ
ไม่มีไปน่ะ
ไม่มีโห
ครูเอ๋ต้องมีอันนี้ค่ะครูเรียมมี
ไฟฉาย
ไปขาย
มีไฟฉาย
แล้วก็เดินเดินเดิน
พ่อ
กับแม่
พูดว่าโอเคไปที่วัดแล้วก็ 1 ชั่วโมงกลับ
นะ
อ๋อก้า
จะ 19:00 น
20:00 น
20:00 น 4 คน
ต้องเดินๆ
กลับบ้าน
เนื้อคู่เรียมคิดครูเอ๋กลับบ้านมั้ย
เรียงคิดว่าไม่
เด้งเด็กหญิง
ชนกไม่กลับจนเที่ยงคืน
โคตรจนดึกมาก
[เพลง]
นะที่วัดบอกเสร็จแล้วเสร็จแล้ว
เสียบกลับบ้านเฮ้ย
ปิดปิ๊บปิดแล้วเสร็จแล้ว
เด็กๆแต่ทุกคนก็เลยโอเคกลับนี่แม่เตรียม
สงสัยค่ะครูเอ๋ทำอะไรที่วัด
ดูเนื้อ
ดูกระดูกกระทง
เราก็ดูรำไทยหอรู้เอนดูอยู่แบบนานมากๆนาน
มาก
สนุกๆแล้วกับฟังใช่ไหมมีคนๆๆร้องเพลง
เอกดูดูดู
แล้วก็กินหมูอ๋อ
แล้วตอนครูเอ๋เด็กๆตัวเล็กๆครูเอ๋มี
นาฬิกาไหมคะไม่มีค่ะ
สู้โอ๋เอ๋ไม่ตั้งนาฬิกาแล้วคู่เอ๋แจง
ไม่ดูเลยค่ะไม่ดูนาฬิกาแต่ว่าอาจะมีบ้าน
นี้ใช่มั้ยบ้านนี้น่ะบ้านนี้เนี่ยก็จะมี
ผู้ใหญ่ผู้ใหญ่ผู้ใหญ่ก็คืออายุ 30 ปี
เนื้อสามสิบสี่นะไปใช่มั้ยก็จะต้องดูเอง
กับกับเก๋ก็หนี
ผู้ใหญ่มีนาฬิกาใช่มะพ่อแม่บอกดูเอ๋น่ะ
เอากับแต่เอ๋กับพี่มีนี่ๆ
ตัวเองวิ่งๆแล้วก็ตลอดไปหรอก
[เพลง]
เพื่อนคุณพ่อก็อันนี้เป็นเพื่อนใช่ไหม
เพื่อนเพื่อนของพ่อ
ไม่เห็นเอ๋ไม่เห็นถ้าพี่ไม่เห็นน้องที่
ไหนที่ไหนดีขอ
หนีหนี้
1 คน 1 คนรอเป็นคนรอไปเอกก็หมีไงหนี
แล้วก็จน
งานที่วัดเสร็จวัดปกปิดปิดกลับบ้านกลับ
บ้าน
ทวดทองคิดกลับบ้านแล้ว
กลับยังไง
ตัวเอกก็เดินเดินกลับบ้านไหมคะครูเรียม
มัน
เที่ยงคืนมือ
เห็นมีไฟฉาย
ไฟฉาย 1
แล้วต้องเดินเดินๆๆก็จะมีครูเอ๋มีพี่มี
น้องแล้วก็มีเพื่อนเด็กๆก็เดินเดินเดิน
แล้วก็หนาวเอกก็มีไฟฉายให้ไปถ่าย
แล้วกำลังเดินเดินเดิน
ที่วัดเนี่ยจากวัดเนี่ยกูเรียงจากวัดณ
วัดนะเราเดินออกมา
โอเคยังมีไฟนิดหน่อยแล้วก็เดินแล้วทุก
อย่างก็เงียบ
เงียบเงียบไม่ได้ยินเสียงเสียงนก
[เพลง]
ขนลุก
เอกขอดื่มน้ำก่อนนะ
[เพลง]
ก็ไม่ได้ยินเสียงคนลุกเลยใช่หาคนมุกเลย
เสร็จแล้วก็เดินเดินเดินมา
ขอโทษครับ
มีเสียงหมาเข้าห้อง
ไหมคะห้องไม่มี
กูอื่นมา
เชิญมาจนถึงตรงนี้ครูเรียม
คู่เอกพูดตรงนี้ตรงนี้ตรงนี้มีบ้านไทย
บ้านทรงไทย
คือ
บ้านไทย
and ไม้
หมู่บ้านไม้ไม้
งู
เสร็จแล้วนะครูเลี่ยม
เดินมากำลังจะถึงทุกคนค่ะทุกคนรู้บ้านไม้
มีผี
ทุกคนกลัวทุกคนก็เดินเดินแล้วก็ได้ยินได้
ยินเสียงอะไรคะพี่
อา
หมูรู๋บอกว่าหมาหอน
แสดงว่าหมาเห็นผี
[เพลง]
แล้วก็ด้านขวามือทางนี้
บ้านบ้านไทย
คู่เลี้ยงถ้าครูเรียนรู้ตรงเนี้ยบ้านไทย
มีผี
มีคนคนพูดบ้าเนี้ยมีผี
คูเรียมได้ยินเสียง
กูเลี้ยงจะฉันไหมฮะไม่ไม่หัน a  hundred
บีไม่หัน
ลล์ไม่หันไม่หาญเอ้ยเออไม่ได้ดู
ถ้าไม่ดูใช่ไหม
คู่เรียมกลัวใช่ค่ะ
ใจค่ะครูเอกก็กลัวเพราะว่าช่อง
แล้วคู่เอ๋ฮันสันไปดูไหมคะคู๋คลิปไม่หัน
ไม่หันอ่าแต่ที่บอกเอ๋ดูเหลนอะไร FM ไม่
ดูพี่บอกดู
ทำไม
หมา
หอน
[เพลง]
หมาหมา
ก็บอกโอเคทุกคนหัน
อุ้ย 4 คน 5
คนทุกๆคนหันไปดูฉันใจค่ะกูเรียม
ครูเอ๋เห็นอะไรคะทุกคนเห็นเหมือนกันค่ะกู
เลียม
รู้บ้านจริงๆบ้านจะดำๆมืดมืด
แล้วก็พระจันทร์มีมีเมฆ
นิ้วหนูนี่เมะ
เมฆกุ้งเราเห็นอันนี้เลยค่ะกูเรียนม
รถ
กูเห็นที่นี่ค่ะทุเรียนเห็นปุ๊บ
จะได้เขียนอันนี้ค่ะอะไรคะเห็นเหมือนคน
สูงมากกว่าบ้าน
แม่
นี่แล้วก็เห็นมือ
เปื่อยใหญ่
ใหญ่ๆ
1  2  3  4  4  5  5 5คนไหมคะพบตอนนั้น 6
คนเด็กๆ 6 คน
เห็น
เห็นทุกคนทุกคนเห็นแล้วก็มีผู้ใหญ่มาอีก
หนึ่งคนก็เห็น
แล้วก็เพราะเห็นเด็กๆ
ตัว a วิ่งไหมคะพี่เอ๋นะแต่ตอนแรกไม่วิ่ง
เอง
แต่แบบผู้ใหญ่ทูตผี
[ปรบมือ]
เพราะผีทุกคนวิ่งหมดเลยทุกๆคนวิ่ง
คู่เอกก็ได้อุ้ย
มินิมาราธอน
วิ่ง
กลับมาที่บ้านรู้เหมาถึงที่บ้านกี่โมงคะ
โอ้ยน่าจะประมาณอุ่นจริงๆหนึ่งชั่วโมงใช่
ไหมต้อง 1 ชั่วโมงเดินเดินแล้วนั้น
น่าจะประมาณเที่ยงคืน
45 อ๋อคิดว่านะคิดว่านะ
อาวุดผีน่ากลัวใช่มั้ยทุกคนก็วิ่ง
ร้องไห้ร้องไห้ร้องไห้เพราะว่าเอ๋อยู่
ข้างหลัง
พี่น้องวิ่งเร็วมากกูเองรอดู
เขาวิ่งว่าที่บ้านโอ้วคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่ว่ายังไงบ้างคะ
คุณแม่มีไม้
คุณแม่
ชีโมง
เวลากี่โมง
1 ชั่วโมงทำไมมาเที่ยงคืนตีหนึ่งแล้ว
แต่ว่าเอ๋กับพี่ๆ
[เพลง]
คุณแม่ก็เลยโอเคอ๋อ
คุณแม่ไม่ตีใช่ไหมคะ
ตอนแรกคุณแม่คิดปี
เพราะว่าบอก 1 ชั่วโมงแต่ 4 คนหนีใช่ไหม
งั้นเนี่ยต้องตีแต่ว่าทุกคนกลับมาแล้วนะ
ผีผี 8 แม่บอกไม่มีนี้มีผีมีมี
ทุกคนกลัวมากๆโคเรียมง้อกูเอกจำได้เป็น
วันอาทิตย์
วันอาทิตย์จำวันที่ไม่ได้แม่บอกไม่มีไม่
มีคุณอา
ฮะโอเค
พ่อกับแม่ไม่ตีอ่ะมาๆก็ไปแปรงฟันร้านมือ
ล้างหน้าร้านค้าวาแล้วก็ไปนอน
นอน
แต่ก็เช้าตื่นขึ้นมา
ตื่นขึ้นมาแล้วครูเอ๋โอเคไหมคะ
จุ๊บๆ
คู่เอกต้องไปแล้วนะคะอ่ะกลางวันใช่ไหมคะ
กูเองวันไปไหนคะ
กลางวันต้องไปก็มีวัดใช่ไหมคะอันนี้ใช่
ค่ะมองไม่เห็นนะไม่เป็นไร
นี้มัด
ตรงนี้โรงเรียน
เงินโรงเรียนอะ
คุณครูเอ๋ต้องไปเรียนหนังสือคือต้องไป
ไปเรียนหนังสือ
ขอโทษนะคะโรงเรียนจะมีธงออกมีทุ่งมีธง
มีธง
เก๋ค่ะก็ต้องไปหาไป
จากบ้าน
ไป
ครูเอ๋โรงเรียน
เดินไปโรงเรียนหรอคะเดินเดินเดินไปโรง
เรียนสามกิโลเมตร
งูก็ต้องผ่านบ้านผี
ครูได้หันไปดูไหมคะเอกก็เดินเดินๆ
แต่ว่าตรงเนี้ยกูกูเรียมจะมีซอยเข้าไป
แล้วก็ถ้าเราไปแล้วก็
ใกล้
ให้
กูเอก
เดินๆก็ไม่มีผีไม่มีผีกลางวันกลางวันมี
พระอาทิตย์
โอเคพระอาทิตย์ไม่มีผีเอกก็เดินเดินๆและ
หน่อยนะ
อะไรคะ
เข้าใจแล้ว
ใช่ไหมคะเฮ้ย
ที่บ้านนี้
มี
จังวันมีต้นไม้
เออ
หลายที่นี่ก็มีแบบนี้ฮือ
ฮือต้นไม้นักเรียนทาจะเป็นต้น
ต้นแบบนี้
แล้วก็มีแบบนี้นะ
ขึ้นมาหายขอต้นไม้ใช่
โอ้โห
ดูเองละอันนี้มันมันก็มีใบอันนี้ร่วงลงมา
ที่นี่
[เพลง]
แล้วก็ที่บ้านเนี้ยตรงนี้ค่ะก็มี mobile
เวลามีลม
[เพลง]
ขอคนดีเสียง
จุ๊ๆคนคิดผี
เตรียมก็คิดผี
จริงๆไม่ใช่ผีค่ะอ่อน
Happy  Ending
คือต้นไม้เป็นไม้ต้นไม้แบบนี้
แบตกาดเป็นแบบนี้
[เพลง]
ไม่คุยให้ดูการคืนการคืน
กางคืนทุกๆ
ลบใจเลยการคืนร้านคือ
การคืนมองไม่เห็นใช่ไหมคะตั้งคืนมองไม่
เห็นมองไม่เห็นใครค่ะผี
นักเรียนนักเรียนฟังตัว a นักเรียนครัว
กลัวใช่ไหมคะ
หรือว่าไม่กลัว
อะไรอะไรอ่ะอยู่
กะกลางวัน
กลางวัน
ไม่ใช่ผี
ไม่ใช่ผีค่ะ
โอเค
โหแบบคนไทยก็คิดมีผีจริงๆค่ะครูเรียน
ใช่ค่ะสรุปแล้วลูกเอ๋ก็ไม่เคยเห็นไม่ไหว
ไม่ใช่ผี
เห็นไหมเคยเห็นมั้ยอ๋อ
ฟังจนถึงอินเทอร์มีเดียทแอดวานซ์คู๋จะพูด
นะ Ghost  Story ความจริง
แต่ตอนนี้นะบีกินเนอะโอเคไม่ใช่ผี
โอเคค่ะโคริยังใช้ค่ะเวลาเลยแล้วจะหมด
เวลาแล้วค่ะหมดนานแล้วสิมาหน้าไร่อ่ะโอเค
บ๊ายบายค่ะบ๊ายบายค่ะเจอกับครูเอ๋เรียง
คลิปหน้าค่ะสวัสดีค่ะถ้า